Perform a sequence of
transformations to try to map
the movable figure-- that's
this figure right over here--
onto C-O-R-A-L or CORAL.
So C-O-R-A-L is this
polygon right over here.
And then we have to figure
out, are these two figures
congruent?
So they're congruent if,
through some combination
of translations,
rotations, and reflections,
I can make this figure sit right
on top of figure C-O-R-A-L.
So let's use this tool
right over here to do that--
to do some translations,
rotations, and reflections.
And so the first
thing I want to do,
let me translate it so they
get close to each other.
And let me see if I can
get one point in common.
So just like that,
I've been able to get
this point in common.
And it seems like, if these
are going to be congruent,
that those would
correspond to each other.
And now it looks
pretty clear that these
are reflections of each other.
So let me reflect them.
So it looks like if I were
to put my point right there
and if I go right
in between, it looks
like if I reflect right
along that, actually, I
might end up being done.
And I am done.
So just with that little
translation followed
by reflection, I was
able to make these two
figures sit on
top of each other.
So these are
definitely congruent.